mon premier jour en France c'était ici à
la rue de berkampf à Paris dans un
quartier très vivant au deuxième étage
de cet immeuble
j'avais déjà quitté Naples en 2008 donc
à mes 18 ans pour faire un peu les tours
du monde avec ma pizza et quand je suis
arrivé à l'aéroport j'ai pris un auberge
il m'a laissé tout en bas de la roue ici
et je me rappelle il pleuvait donc ma
valise ça casse je commence à tirer pour
tout la roue j'étais tout mouillé je me
suis retrouvé ici pour avec ma famille
avec compression que je connaissais pas
dans 13 mètres carrés donc tu as plus de
dignité des fois des souris qui se
baladaient mais regardez sa sortie de la
pâte et après trois jours j'avais deux
choses avec moi dans cet appartement
alors dis et en Playstation et je me
suis fait cambrioler mon opinion de la
France était quand même un pays de Nord
donc moi je vais aller surtout de Naples
et donc c'était un peu difficile
d'imaginer de vivre pour longtemps dans
un pays un peu froid les Français il dit
qu'il les Italiens ils sont des Français
des bonhomores moi j'ai trouvé un niveau
incroyable ici des gens qui vraiment ils
reconnais au mauvais pizza dans une
bonne je viens de Naples quartier
espagnol il s'appelle c'est au
centre-ville et c'est un quartier un peu
chaud dedans j'ai quitté l'école à mes
15 ans parce que voilà ma maman elle a
fait deux ans de travail je devais
chercher les moyens de faire un peu
d'argent pour aider ma maman et moi à
vivre et je suis tombé sur une pizzeria
des quartiers et bon côté enfant et tout
regarde d'un peu les mouvements
artistiques d'un pittéro qui fait
tourner la pâte c'est quand même
intéressant tous les enfants il aime ça
je suis tombé amoureux tout de suite de
cette savoir-faire la première pizza
c'était complètement dégueulasse
complètement cramé il avait un trou au
milieu comme ça mais j'ai la manger avec
un satisfaction comme si c'était la
meilleure place du monde parce que
c'était moi qui l'avait fait avec mes
mains et c'était la première fois qu'il
dans ma vie
j'avais fait quelque chose
maintenant il me reconnaît dans la rue
il me dit bonjour c'est incroyable je
dois dire merci à la France
moi quand je cuisine je rentre dans un
monde à part je me sens pas sur la terre
en fait déjà l'essence des toucher la
pâte de crier des choses des zéro
jusqu'à quai ça arrive à table au client
et la satisfaction du client qui te
regarde comme j'ai passé un moment à bon
moment pour moi il y a pas de métier et
qui te donne à satisfaction à Paris
[Applaudissements]
je suis allé voir plusieurs banques et
tout le monde m'a dit non c'était
compliqué un traitant je suis allé à
Naples pour la cinquième fois l'édition
de championnat du monde des pizzeria et
j'ai gagné donc je suis devenu meilleur
pitié lot du monde 2019
je suis rentré à Paris avec mon titre
j'ai trouvé finalement l'argent pour
ouvrir les restaurants et
j'ai démarré cette restaurant 2020 le
jour de mon anniversaire 16 mars
2020 Macron à la télé il annonce la
ferme à tout de tous les réseaux en
France je savais pas quoi faire je ferme
la porte je rentre chez moi je commence
à pleurer j'ai dit à ma femme je sais
pas comment passer sortir
[Musique]
ça c'est la pizza qui m'a changé la vie
c'est la pizza champion du monde j'ai
voulu reprendre tous les sens du papier
gustatives qu'il y en a dans la bouche
les croquants les salaires les douches
c'est un petit voyage à travers tout
l'expérience que j'ai fait à travers le
monde
on la mange maintenant
on a le droit de mettre de l'ananas sur
la pizza bon il est un des choses qui en
faut pas faire c'est comme l'ananas sur
la pizza